[Music]
Jack you have the question how do we
remove gravity from the anti-gravity
chambers that astronauts trained in and
you've probably seen films of astronauts
and training floating around in a closed
chamber and it does kind of look like we
may have something that can actually
shield against gravity well for one
thing I I really wish we did because I
mean just think about how useful that
would be think about having say a
construction yellow site and you can
remove all of the gravity you could
actually move things around really
easily there's so many applications for
having some sort of anti-gravity device
but we don't have one there is no way to
shield astronauts here on the earth from
the effects of gravity we train
astronauts by putting them up in an
airplane and then having the airplane
fly very very carefully on an ark to
throw everybody up at just the right
rate so they're floating it may have
actually happened to you you may have
been on an airplane and the airplane
actually sort of arced around and you
felt yourself throwing up a little bit
so that's actually what we do in a very
controlled way we only can get about a
minutes worth of weightlessness that way
the airplane flies an arc and then goes
around again and flies another one so
the astronauts trained by doing this
over and over and over again one of the
really amazing applications of this was
in the movie Apollo 13 if you look very
carefully that's a very realistic
depiction of astronauts floating around
in the weightlessness of space and
that's because they really were
weightless they actually put movie sets
inside this aircraft and filmed one
minute at a time the footage of the
astronauts floating around the lunar
module for example now this sort of
training where one minute you're
weightless and then all of a sudden
you're not and then you're weightless
again has a bit of an effect on people's
stomach and in fact the the NASA
nickname for this plane is the vomit
comet
it's it's something that can actually
make you feel pretty sick to your
stomach but a lot of astronauts and
training also find it really fun and the
I've heard it mentioned that there are
some pilots that are better than others
at doing just the right arc there's some
pilots that as you fly you're up against
the ceiling that up against the floor
and up against the ceiling and then
there are ones that get really really
smooth so you have the longest possible
time and weightlessness in fact I heard
that the pilot that was best at it would
actually put a pen
in front of him as he began the arc to
make it make it feel like you were
weightless and then he would fly the
plane around the pencil trying to keep
that pencil in the same position as he
went through the weightlessness arc so
there's no way we can shield from
gravity we only can train astronauts a
minute at a time in these aircraft the
other way we train them is by simulating
a weightless environment the best we can
by using water by using really really
big swimming pools at the Johnson Space
Center one of my favorite places to go
at all of NASA there is a swimming pool
a pool so big that we actually have an
entire scale model of the space station
underneath the water the same size as
the space station we put astronauts in
you know basically scuba gear they they
have their helmets there's air being
pumped through there and they can float
around and practice doing spacewalks
outside the space station in the water
and then all around them there are
actually real scuba divers ready to
assist them to make sure everything's
going well and I've had friends who have
actually served this way they've
actually been scuba divers that help
astronauts train so unfortunately
there's no way to shield from gravity
here on the earth gravity is a curvature
of space and time
we have no way to manipulate that with
our current technology so we have to
fake it astronauts have to either be in
aircraft that are flying arcs or
pretending to be weightless under the
water and that's the best we can do
[Music]